[Music]
walking dead season ender this amazing
cliffhanger and the story is that an
important character is going to die a
very important character at the start of
the next season and that different
endings have actually been shot to
confuse everybody is that right they're
going to great lengths not to spoil it
right I'll say that you know it's like
one of those things you asked for it
you're gonna get it and yeah you know it
might be rougher than you've you were
expecting wow that's amazing
it's so it's hardcore yeah it's okay
well the show has always been hardcore
but it looks like now they're really
gonna keep this this promise do you know
what's gonna happen I mean I do you do
know okay so you know whether or not cuz
I don't know if I'm talking to a dead
man now or not I have no I have no idea
you know but I don't know yeah yeah I'm
just gonna keep it like that yeah I
really like that job who really wants
you to keep that job yeah the
impersonator I mean you know there's
gonna be bummed out if you if your
character gets killed he's in trouble I
just I mean I I saw a picture of him and
I just thought man I need new clothes
like I need to stop wearing the same
Minor Threat t-shirt every right
you